breaking news best business show
internet exclusive just tweeted it um
all right internet exclusive cade
cunningham first overall pick of the
detroit pistons in the nba draft this
year has signed an exclusive multi-year
deal with crypto company blockfi
there he is
so as part of the deal the interesting
part here is kade will be taking 100 of
his signing bonus in bitcoin
pay me in bitcoin the number one nba
draft pick pay me in bitcoin
cade cunningham taking the whole deal in
bitcoin
we gotta get kate one of those
shirts what up
my man getting paid in bitcoin i mean
can we talk about is this going to
become the norm for athletes now is this
is this the thing like you used to get a
shoe deal now you got to get a a deal
and get paid in bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies
is that just how it works like we've hit
the point where if you don't have one of
these you're not cool it used to be if
you don't get a shoe deal you're not
cool if you don't have one of these
deals you're not cool well so i think
it's uh it's interesting from a few
perspectives we've seen a bunch of guys
do this like another rookie that did it
was trevor lawrence first overall pick
also maybe that's a thing uh but he he
did a deal with blockfolio they paid him
his signing bonus in crypto it was
spread out a few of them but most of it
was uh in uh bitcoin but i think what it
comes down to is like
these deals are a portion of their
investment portfolio right so i think
what they're thinking about is like i
need exposure to this industry so
they're certainly interested in in what
we've seen from a lot of the guys we've
talked to uh throughout sports and
entertainment but at the same time maybe
it's a two percent allocation maybe it's
a five percent maybe it's ten percent
even of their investment portfolio but
they're getting invested they're getting
exposure to the industry they're
learning about it and i think it's good
i think we'll continue to see it over
time as these companies continue to
deploy capital in the marketing space
and we'll see uh more athletes get
involved yo block five baller stuff
right here yeah that's pretty cool i'm
an investor i'm on the board all the
disclosures read terms and conditions
block five killing it can we can we
shark attack cade right now should we do
it yeah how pissed is he all right hold
on i'm gonna put kade's twitter handle
into the youtube chat here's what we're
gonna do i want everyone to go tweet at
cade cunningham right now and just say
pay me a bitcoin just go flood his mesh
uh mentions and retweet my
literally just go flood kade
cunningham's uh entire twitter
notifications with pay me a bitcoin and
let's see what uh let's see what he says
i'm not to take uh the blame if he gets
mad i'm going to say joe said to do it
this that's cool we'll scrub the video
no problem but everyone go flood cud uh
cade cunningham's mentions right now you
got that right nicholas joey doubles
let's go i i mean darren rovell didn't
have this story he didn't have the stuff
hey well well let's be clear the taurus
was passed yeah
he passed that's why
i was like hey we're going to give this
to you that we saw the torch being
passed
how many sources did you have to talk to
today to get all the details i was all
over the place yeah i saw i saw him
earlier he had up uh slack he had up
text and he had up twitter dms and he
was just
a little computer with steam coming out
of his ears
but you got the news got the news it's
out there kade cunningham getting paid
in bitcoin i mean that
we like to joke around his twitter right
that's his twitter right there go just
blow him up
let's see if uh are people doing it woes
bomb you right evan whoa woes bomb
uh oh
uh a little bit a little bit we got a
couple of oh yeah oh yeah okay all right
yeah there's a lot of people who are
tweeting that up all right keep going
keep tweeting just keep tweeting at him
and uh i think that he might be like oh
this bitcoin thing is pretty cool um i
do think that this is going to become
the norm for athletes where they say all
right i'm coming out of school or maybe
even in school i'm surprised that we
haven't seen some big deals uh with
college athletes but they say look i
need a shoe deal i need an apparel deal
and i need a bitcoin or crypto deal
right and what's gonna end up happening
is there's so many companies in the
industry that have so much money and
they're all trying to get out of just
marketing to the same uh bitcoin or
crypto audience that they're going to
start trying to get into the mainstream
they're going to try to break out into
sports other things we've seen uh ftx uh
who's got a ton of deals they've done
major league baseball all that
crypto.com they just announced a uh one
with was it serie a right the italian uh
league um and then also they've done f1
blockfy now they've done everyone from
matt james who was the uh the bachelor
to uh cade cunningham the number one
draft pick in uh the nba draft like this
is going to be the norm yeah but i think
it's only the norm to be honest for
people who are of high value stature
right like you don't see the fifth
string
linemen on a d3 is school getting this
yeah well they don't get endorsement
deals regardless right it's all the guys
they don't even get free lunch they
really gotta pay for school if you're
the fifth string d-lineman you don't
even get a scholarship yeah so it's it's
a part of it right like the it's
it's not necessarily broadening the
reach of the people that are getting
endorsement deals to your point but i
think more of it is about the quality
and the type of endorsement deal they're
getting so these guys are more open to
it and they know that they're it's a
crypto company they're endorsing right
whether it's bitcoin or whatever and
they want to be paid in that in that uh
in that crypto because it gives them
exposure to the industry so i think cade
uh taking his his signing bonus and
bitcoin was smart i think trevor the
same thing we're seeing athletes do it
salary wise saquon's doing it with his
endorsement money etc all these guys
want exposure to the industry so it's
how can i get creative about doing it
earn money through the endorsement deal
as it is and buy some crypto with it hey
guys thanks so much for watching that
clip of the best business show make sure
you like and subscribe to the channel
turn on notifications so you know when
we go live every weekday and then head
to sofi.com so that you can get an
account we can get after it